[Music]
welcome to every damn day today South
Park preview right here there has to be
something we can still do please mr.
Gore you're the only person who knows
anything about it
say you're sorry for making fun of me we
didn't we didn't realize there were born
you're sorry for making fun of me
we're sorry for making fun of you that
didn't sound serial at all Al Gore's
back we get a good man Bear Pig anybody
I think that cartoon is better-looking
than the real Al Gore I don't know if he
looks terrible but you know here he is
endorsing a penguin for Congress I don't
think he looks back my whole thing is
like I hadn't seen Al Gore since he was
you know doing his thing however many
years ago and now it's back whoa like it
was just like a shocking yeah 18 years
really didn't suit him very well today
where's he been I guess like building a
wormhole for when the world goes he's
been working with Jaden Smith doing some
water stuff I hope so that's what Al
Gore's up to in real life environmental
stuff as we know but he's been on South
Park for a long time hunting the
manbearpig let's check it out back it up
right there what does that look like to
you
it's manbearpig I told you it was real
look again they're half man half bear
and half peg do you see it yes we see it
mr. Gore something big is going on and
the American people need to know what
I'm off we got it trust Al Gore we gotta
trust a man bare pig guys it's science
the enemy of the people
anybody yeah I do think that science is
Stana me of people because it proves the
Bible wrong and this has caused a lot of
problems it's like we had one book more
books more people thinking for
themselves
yeah no pain in my rear done just things
without science Natasha and I could be
at home making food what are you guys
gonna be cooking up for me yum yum yum I
really like as I mentioned before to
just heat bricks of cheese up on a plate
sometimes they get a real liquidy just a
spoon ISM has given us it's just cheese
all right yeah I was trying to like go
along with though like Hannah's thing I
am trying to have fun also a big
shout-out to your voted sticker so let's
check out this next clip right now mr.
president mr. president I believe we
have a serious problem the environment
is changing
even is somehow reacting to our presents
own it and what do you base this off
look this is the world right but now
think of the world as a living being if
it were somehow conscious then it would
ultimately become aware of our effect on
it right the world is conscious it makes
perfect sense hello anybody if we have
made too much of an impact then that
consciousness would try to snuff us out
I think we're looking at a global
catastrophe the likes of which we've
never seen
pull generate and poppycock I think we
need to put all resources now into a
full investigation perhaps even begin a
lie swine evacuation evacuation
tomorrow is the KU tak festival you know
how much money we would lose escort mr.
Mayfield out the president can't be
bothered any further damn you fast
president Craig you could be killing his
own okay a couple questions off of that
clip should they have trusted that louse
is that Laos a metaphor for Al Gore so
the only one impressed with me using the
singular form of the word lice all those
questions let's start with Jordan you
look really smart thank you I'm gonna
say you did not look smart because the
fact that you know Natacha give my time
to hand it just shows absolutely the kid
that was getting like the it's called
dandruff it's actually a yeast infection
on my head thank you very much
my well half the hall in college got
lice and I was not one of those people
oh it's too dangerous in there
inhospitable yeah the girl that works
here I told you there was a girl that
works here that uh was at the Halloween
party and asked what came up to me and
was like hey I've been watching the show
I really like it but let me have a quick
question for you are you supposed to be
a dick what do you mean like you're
always mean to Han I'm like she's mean
to me she's like yeah but you're mean
back I think we just have great
chemistry
no I yeah I'm a dick you guys do I look
smart that was the question it's what I
am sure I dropped the card no one who is
smart would ever say that do I like
smart as a phrase never said buy a smart
yeah okay someone who wears a shirt that
says I'm fluent in sarcasm I'm gonna
catch it's like you're just not
absolutely not I think it has shirts
that say stuff on it as a bad loss to
say words
that's what sweatshirts are for not
sweaters sweatshirts they say words on
and then you always say things like
sports teams where are you from places
you've been or those two things only so
is this a rocking chair this is not a
should turn it into life there was you
wouldn't be allowed on my porch you
should have like a piece of hair a piece
of straw okay Al Gore let me do this
this is actually perfect because Al Gore
is known for his epic freak-outs on the
show do you think that we're gonna get
one on Wednesday night well I mean I
think so what a clip why won't anybody
listen to me manbearpig is in there and
we have to kill them while we are the
chance on stereo mr. Gore please we need
you to calm down now what exactly do you
suggest we do I told you we need to fill
the cave with hot molten lead cuz it's
the only way to make sure member pig
never comes out and I'm saying it I'm
totally cereal but I know it just kids
digging well see the problem is that if
we fill the caves with hot molten land
it will kill those boys too there
ready that did you listen to me they got
attacked by manbearpig and manbearpig
leaves nobody alive i'm super-cereal
material do you want me to get the
ex-vice president out of here not i feel
kind of bad for him i don't think he has
any friends that's my life today i get
the cards i get all this stuff and I get
no respect anybody have a aunt you ask
your own question I'm out I'll be your
friend man thanks it's nice can you hand
me that back yeah so the question he
said so that's really what we're here to
do we're here to predict mm-hmm I think
he doesn't freak out he just chills out
because he realizes climate change
doesn't really exist it's like pretty
cool that side no I bet he does a little
bit does that show up on camera am I got
a prediction I bet he's gonna team up
with Jaden Smith in the news and I think
they together Jaden Smith is too cool Al
Gore is not cool enough together they
will be the perfect mix of just cool
that's right from the article we were
reading this morning about Jaden Smith I
found a quote from Jaden Smith but I
think proves that he's like not at all
cool because the quote Smith said the
best way is found to convince peers to
care about climate change was is to
quote scare them as bad as I can
honestly because kids in my generation
they're just like oh I'm tough I don't
care I'll be fine I'll just go skate the
rest of my life and I say bro if the
skate parks floods you're gonna have to
learn how to surf and he sounds like
that's just crazy middle-aged man
pretending to go to like you dress up as
a young kid and be like if the skate
parks people like to sir oh that's like
not a very good decision like why we
should care about
learn how to serve Hana who is the last
person that you screamed at my wall this
when's the last time that you lost your
temper oh boy
you ever raise your voice I can't
imagine you screaming no I'm really a
screamer I just kind of shut down if I'm
mad I just go I just internalized yeah
take ever like screamed at a person but
I have screamed about a person yeah no
no I've never screamed at a person the
last fight I can she was my husband we
were he was saying I'm very
scatterbrained and I was like absolutely
not I am so organized and know
everything and then in the middle of the
fight I'm like where's our dog I had
accidentally locked him in the closet we
were having the whole fight about how I
don't pay attention do you have a shout
out I do wish you didn't know where it
was this comes from mo Oz and he said
our question was why is Nic Cage an
alien and he said because isn't it weird
how his name is caged but in a way he
frees our souls it truly is the Hannah
Dickinson of movie stars really great
that was from yesterday's episode where
he talked about the five reasons why Nic
Cage is an alien I think Jordan has
something to follow up with it's very
funny that you say that because Lo has
also comes into my Instagram 21 hours
ago before you chose the comment you and
see this comment this comment he said
and I still haven't been the shadow of
the day even though I comment every damn
day well no as your dreams have come
true
you can now die peacefully Jesus thank
you for watching everybody especially mo
as this has been every damn day check us
out on Twitter for our extra damn day
show and we'll be back tomorrow with
something different
[Music]